there
were some comments earlier on tuesday
from seahawks receiver tyler locke that
i just want to mention briefly he said
that he expects russell wilson to be on
the seahawks for the foreseeable future
now i don't know what that means because
really most football players don't
foresee much of a future beyond the
coming season
because every season is kind of its own
entity now in the national football
league the teams change so much there's
never going to be another 2021 seahawks
2022 guys will be gone new guys will
come
changes will be made quite possibly with
coaching staff and and and it's a new
thing when the next season rolls around
so foreseeable future to me as far as
the nfl is concerned foreseeable future
is a year and so
in that respect i agree with tyler
lockett because i expect russell wilson
to be the quarterback of the seahawks
for all of the 2021 season after the
season
what happens i believe is going to
depend in large part on how this season
goes
if it goes very well for the seahawks if
they get back to the nfc championship
for the first time since 2014 and yes
it's been that long since they've been
into the final four for the nfl
then maybe russell wilson signs up for
another year
if they fail again to get beyond the
wild card round or beyond the divisional
round we may hear some of the same
things we heard directly from wilson in
february and the things that came from
his agent about the teams that he would
accept to trade to you know tyler
lockett tries to downplay all of this as
the media looking for things to talk
about during the slow time first of all
it's not slow in february and march
there's plenty of other stuff happening
and when a guy's agent a franchise
quarterbacks agent one of the best
quarterbacks in the game one of the best
quarterbacks to ever play the game comes
out and says well my client doesn't want
to be traded but if he were to be traded
here are the four teams he'd accept the
trade to that's never happened before
that's news that's not the media making
something out of nothing that's the
media doing its job
when one of the newsmakers makes
something whether it was wilson in his
comments to dan patrick or agent mark
rogers and his comments to adam schefter
whatever the case it's newsworthy so
don't blame us that it became a story it
became a story because wilson wanted it
to be a story and for now the hatchet
has been buried but that hatchet will be
unburied if the seahawks struggle in
2021
or at least if they struggle to achieve
the kind of success that will help
further cement russell wilson's legacy
this is year 10 for him he's got one
super bowl win two super bowl
appearances and if he's not going to get
more of them with the seahawks he is
going to look for another team where he
can get that kind of achievement on his
resume
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports